[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unbox today we
are checking out nvidia's new GeForce
RTX 470 TI super a product named so
poorly that you would be forgiven for
thinking it's a meme but no the ti super
is now actually a thing and as silly as
it sounds the specs do look pretty great
16 GB of vram using ad 103 silicon so it
should perform rather well but before we
find out today's sponsor spot is brought
to you by Asus and their latest range of
z790 motherboards supporting 12 13th and
14th generation Intel core processors
for those of you seeking a budget
friendly option one of our favorite z790
motherboards is the tough gaming z790
Plus available in either ddr4 or ddr5
variants with and without Wi-Fi there's
also the recently updated version called
the tough gaming z790 Pro featuring ddr5
exclusively but for those of you seeking
something a bit more high-end we've
tested a number of excellent z790 STS
boards and for my personal gaming system
I'm using the Rog strix z790 F gaming
Wi-Fi Which packs loads of USB 3 ports
PD 3.13 W charging and a powerful vcor
vrm using 16 990 amp power stages and
right now for Australian viewers you'll
receive a free Corsair Vengeance RGB 32
GB ddr5 6000 C 36 memory kit when you
purch purchase select Asus z790
motherboards with an Asus all-in-one
liquid cooler so for more information
please check the link in the video
description okay so unlike other 4070
class products the 4070 TI super moves
away from the a104 silicon and instead
uses the same 0103 silicon as the RTX
480 now these upgrades should help the
4070 TI super better compete with the
radon RX 7900 XT which is now regularly
available for $750 us for rization
performance the 7900 XT easily beat the
472 and armed with 20 GB of vram it felt
like a true high-end offering despite
the weaker rate tracing performance
which is still quite an issue anyway
let's take a look at the performance and
then we'll dive into the cost per Frame
data for testing we're using our ryzen 7
7800x 3D test system with 32 GB of DDR
56000 memory using the latest display
driv
all data has been validated and updated
for this video and in total we've tested
12 games some with and without ra
tracing enabled and the resolutions of
focus for this review are 1440p and 4K
okay let's get into it actually before
we get into the results a quick note on
a last minute issue that cropped up I
filmed this section just had to add it
last minute and that's because just a
day before the review was set to go live
Nvidia reached out informing us that
there was a potential performance
related ISS issue with the MSI RTX 470
TI super Ventus 3x GPU and that was a
problem because I did most of my testing
with that model now Nvidia claimed they
discovered an issue with the MSI model
where performance was approximately 5%
below where it should be when compared
to other aib models they didn't really
specify if it was up to 5% slower in
some instances or whether this was an
overall thing but regardless this was a
problem because my review uh well it
needed to be retested and that would
take days and days of my time not to
mention having to recreate all the
graphs update the script re-record
dually editing all that sort of stuff so
despite all that I dropped everything
and decided to investigate by testing
the Asus tough gaming model which
thankfully I did have on hand after
going over all of the data I found at
most a 4% increase in a single title at
just one of the tester resolutions and
most games saw at most a 1% increase so
pretty typical performance variance
there between aib models now after
speaking with m I they confirmed mixed
reports with some seeing a little to no
difference between the Ventus 3x and
something like a tough gaming like
myself While others saw up to a 5%
difference now given how small the
change was in my testing I have stuck
with the original data for this review
as 1% overall isn't really going to
change anything but in any case I will
update the 4072 super data for upcoming
RTX 280 super review next week so you'll
have the most accurate possible data 1%
or otherwise anyway let's get back into
the data I promise we're about to go
over all of the graphs first up we have
a plague Tower reum and at 1440p using
the ultra quality preset but with rate
tracing disabled so we will look at the
rate tracing results soon anyway here
the 4070 TI super spat out 104 FPS
making it 7% slower than the 17900 XT
and just 5% faster than the original
4070 TI then jumping up to 4K sees the
ti super slip further behind the 7900 XT
now trailing by a 9% margin with 60 FPS
on average next up we have Resident Evil
4 and at 1440p this time the ti super is
faster than the 7900 XT though only by a
mere 5% margin which meant it was just
4% faster than the 4070 TI which is a
bit of a disappointing result increase
in the resolution to 4K was enough to
see the 79 XT hit the lead though the ti
super was just 3% slower so performance
overall was basically the same
here now moving on to Cy Punk 2077 you
might be surprised to find the ti super
Trails the 1700 XT here by a 9% margin
at 1440p though keep in mind we are yet
to enable R tracing also quite
disappointing to see is the fact that
the 4070 TI super was just 3% faster
than the original 47
TI pumping up the resolution to 4K
though did favor the 1700 XT a little
bit more and now the ti super is 7%
slower though it is also 6% faster than
the standard 4070
TI Hogwarts Legacy was tested using the
ultra quality preset and at 1440p we
find that the ti super is 10% slower
than the 1700 XT and disappointingly
really no faster than the original 4070
TI then at 4K it slips behind the 1700
XT by a 14% margin only matching the old
6950 XT though oddly it is now 23% FAS
than the RTX 4070
TI next up is Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 3 and this one's been tested
using the extreme preset and of course
we will start with the 1440p data here
the ti super is 23% slower than the 7900
XT and bizarrely 4% slower than the 4070
TI which frankly shouldn't be possible
however I'm not the only reviewer to
find this I have spoke with other
reviewers who have seen similar data and
apparently in video are looking into
this so perhaps this is a driver related
issue but at the time of releasing this
video I haven't heard of any
fixes I found that the ti super was much
slower than the standard 4070 TI at
1080p a little slower at 1440p and then
slightly faster at 4K so I'm not exactly
sure what's going on here but in any
case it's going to land quite a way
behind the 7900
XT moving on to Spider-Man remastered we
find performance that's pretty well neck
and neck between the 700 XT and 4070 TI
super with around 200 FPS each that made
the ti super 9% faster than the standard
4070 TI and 10% slower than the RTX 480
and we find much the same at 4K here the
ti super was just 2% slower than the
1700 XT and 5% faster than the standard
TI Now The Last of Us Part One was
tested using the ultra quality preset
and at 1440p we see the 4070 TI super
was good for 100 FPS on average so
basically the same level of performance
you can expect to see from the radon RX
7900 XT in this example that's a 12%
boost over the 4070 TI and just 8%
slower than that of the RTX
480 then at 4K the 700 XT and 470 TI
super we again neck and neck but we do
see a more substantial 177% increase
over the standard 4070
TI the ti super is only offering a very
minor performance bump in Dying Light 2
boosting the 1440p performance by a mere
3% which meant it was 4% slower than the
7900 XT then at 4K it ends up 6% slower
than the radon GPU and a rather pathetic
3% faster than the original model so the
model it's replacing the RTX 4070
TI next up are the Starfield results and
at 1440p the ti super was 6% slower than
the 17900 XT and a mere 1% faster than
the 4070 ti so that makes it all seem a
bit pointless then at 4K it's 8% slower
than the radon GPU and again just a
single frame faster than the original
4070 ti so in this example just a 2%
uplift
Allen wake 2 is one of the newest games
to be added to our test list and it's
both visually impressive and very
demanding on Hardware using the highest
quality preset but rate racing disabled
the ti super is 6% slower than the 7900
XT at 1440p that's because it's just 3%
faster than the original 470 TI and
jumping up to 4K that does knock the
average frame rate of the ti super down
to just 41 FPS making it 5 % slower than
the 7900 XT it was also just 5% faster
than the original 407 tii which makes
this updated model seem yeah a bit
pointless I would say the second last
game tested is Watchdog Legion and here
the ti super is 9% slower than the 7900
XT at 1440p and just 1% faster than the
4070 TI then at 4K it Trail the 700 XT
by a 10% margin with just 94 FPS on
average which is a mere 3 FPS boost over
the original 47
ETI and for the last of the
rasterization results we have Hitman 3
and here the 470 TI super averaged an
impressive 172 FPS at 440p making it 9%
faster than the 1700 XT and 8% faster
than the original 470 ETI increasing the
resolution of 4K though completely flips
the results on their head and now the
4070 TI super is 133% slower than the
1700 XT we're also seeing virtually no
change in performance between the 4070
TI and 470 TI
super okay so here's a look at the 12
game average covering the raster
performance at 1080p the ti super was 6%
slower than the 1700 XT and just 3%
faster than the 47 ETI so pretty
disappointing results there overall now
the margin to the 700 XT was the same at
1440p again the ti sup 6% slower and
just 3% faster than the original 470 TI
So based on that you have to wonder what
is the point finally at 4K it's 9%
slower than the 7900 XT and then 6% FAS
than the 4070 ti so not nearly the
performance uplift we're expecting based
on the
specs okay so what about raate tracing
performance well to find out I've
overhauled our raate tracing benchmarks
adding more titles and increasing the RT
settings the goal here was 60 FPS or
better at 1440p
so if upscaling was required to hit that
FPS Target it was enabled using the
quality setting for either dlss or FSR a
plague toil requium doesn't require
upscaling for 60 FPS or better with the
4070 TI super so we didn't enable it in
this example it was 22% faster than the
1700 XT but just 5% faster than the
original 47 ETI so while a good result
relative to the AMD GPU a pretty poor
performance uplift when compared to the
it's
replacing now for the 470 super review I
did add Avatar but included in the 12
game Benchmark data despite the fact
that it enables raate tracing by default
after careful consideration I've decided
to move Avatar into our raid tracing
bench marks and because you can't
disable ra tracing effects in this title
I did remove it from the 12 game data
the 17900 XT does reasonably well here
anyway as the ti super is just 3% faster
on average the tii super was also just a
frame faster than the 470 ti so again a
much smaller uplift here than what you'd
probably
expect next up we have Resident Evil 4
and here both the 7900 XT and 470 TI
super were good for around 120 FPS so
pretty similar performance there in fact
the ti super is really no better than
the original model so I'm not really
sure what's going on there cyberpunk
2077 Phantom Liberty has been tested
using the r tracing Ultra preset which
requires the a of upscaling for 60fps
gaming so we've enabled quality dlss for
the GeForce gpus and then quality FSR
for the radon gpus sadly though the 1700
XT is UN aable to achieve 60 FPS on
average rendering just 45 FPS the 4070
TI super on the other hand spat out 74
FPS which was the exact same result
produced by the standard 4070
TI Marvel's Spider-Man remastered has
been tested using the very high quality
preset with the very high quality rate
tracing options enabled and despite
maxing out the game we find the 1700 XT
and 4070 TI super a neck and neck with
126 FPS which is also the same
performance seen from the standard 470
TI now performance in Hogwarts Legacy is
somewhat CPU bound even at 1440p which
speaks to how poorly optimized this game
is and as a result most of the higher
end gpus are all producing very similar
performance
now the RTX 47 doesn't require upscaling
to exceed 60 FPS in fortnite at 1440p
with all the ra racing bells and
whistles enabled and as a result it was
27% faster than the 1700 XT here
rendering 62 FPS opposed to 49
FPS Ratchet and Clank a rift apart is a
very poor title for AMD once rate
tracing is enabled in this example the
1700 XT fall short of 60 FPS even with
FSR enabled
meanwhile the 407 tii super spat out 90
FPS using dlss quality mode making it
70% faster than the 7900 XT so a
devastating margin there also just as a
side note I have no idea why the 7700 XT
is broken in this title with rad tracing
enabled I tried multiple driver installs
but each time the game turned into a
complete slideshow this seems like a
driver bug to me so hopefully AMD can
address it
shortly Star Wars yo Survivor does play
better with the Radeon gpus with Road
tracing enabled as we're looking at
similar performance between the 7900 XT
and 4070 TI super with around 80 FPS on
average then finally we have alen wake 2
which is a bloodbath 3D although the
rasterized performance is excellent in
this title from the Radeon gpus enabling
R tracing cripples them to the point
where even upscaling can't make them
usable as a result the 47 tii super was
almost three times faster than the 7900
XT okay so here's a look at the 10 game
average at
440p here we see that on average the
4070 TI super was 27% faster than the
1700 XT and that's a really poor result
for the rad on GPU it's no surprise to
find Nvidia winning the rage racing
benchmarks though the degree to which
they win does depend on the games used
Allen wake 2 for example was a shocker
for AMD and it certainly helped inflate
the margins but it's also a really great
looking game and it's playable using rad
tracing on the 4070 TI super at 1440p so
for me it's a valid result now the only
disappointing result here being the fact
that the 470 TI super is just 4% faster
on average than the original 4070
TI now another big advantage of the
GeForce 40 series is power efficiency in
Hitman for example the 4070 TI super was
9% faster than the 700 XT at 1440p
and yet it was still able to reduce
total system power usage by 8% it's not
exactly blowing the 1700 XT out of the
water here but it's certainly the more
efficient product then taking power
readings while testing with Spider-Man
remastered sees the RTX 472 super
reduced total system consumption by 16%
and that's well delivering the same
level of performance so a 72 W power
saving that's really nothing to scoff at
now it's time for the all important cost
per Frame data and as usual we'll start
with the MSRP figures of course while
the 1700 XT MSRP is still $900 it hasn't
been a $900 product for a long time
basically since its release still
without an official change to the MSRP
we have to go with $900 and that means
the 407 tii super is around 6% better
value per frame so not amazing but it
does make the GeForce GPU a much better
buy sadly though when compared to the
original 4070 TI the new super version
improves value by a mere
3% okay but what about real world
pricing for that we have Newegg and the
first thing I want to address here is
the 1700 XT price of
$750 right now the cheapest 7950 XT on
your EG is actually a discounted ASRock
Phantom gaming model for just $710 that
seems like a pretty good deal then there
are a few XFX and Sapphire models at
$730 with the rest at $750 or more now
the reason I haven't gone with the $710
or even $730 prices is because I believe
these are limited time only deals meant
to reain on nvidia's super parade AMD
themselves have said they're working
with their Partners to make $750 us the
new sweet spot for the 7900 XT so
realistically moving forward it should
be possible to purchase a 1700 XT for
that price and that being the case I'm
going to ignore what I think a limited
time only deals and instead go with the
more realistic long-term price of $750
us that said though I do feel as though
this product really needs an official
price cut to $700 us to become a viable
option at $750 is just an 11% saving per
frame R compared to the 4070 TI super
and that's when looking purely at
rasterization performance if we were to
look at the R Racing data the 1700 XT
would end up costing 19% more per per
frame making the GeForce GPU the obvious
choice for anyone interested in rate
racing the only disappointing aspect of
the 47 TI super is the fact that it's
just 3% better than the original 470 ETI
in terms of value that's not exactly an
exciting update is it it's also 20% more
costly per frame than the 4070 super
offering a mere 11% performance uplift
for a 33% price
premium okay let's have a quick look at
some aib cards and for all of our
testing we used the MSI Ventus 3x as it
was the first 4070 TI super model that
we received this is a base model card
which should be available at the $800 us
MSRP now for testing it was installed
inside an ATX case with the door closed
we had a room temperature of 21°
maintained throughout our testing and
the card was placed under an hour of
gaming load after an hour The Junction
temperature peaked at 69° while the GPU
Hot Spot reached 81 ° the memory also
peaked at 82° and these temperatures
were achieved with a fan speed of, 1400
RPM resulting in an operating volume of
just 32 DB making the Ventus 3x a quiet
graphics card finally the call clock
speed averaged 2,700 MHz and the memory
ran at the stock frequency of
2,625
MHz also on hand for testing was the
assus tough gaming model which should
sell for roughly the MSRP the 40 7 TI
version for example currently costs $810
us with the OC version at $850 us now
look I'm a big fan of these tough gaming
models the all metal design is very nice
it looks great it feels very premium and
it's much nicer than the cheap plastic
fan shrouds that we're all too used to
seeing as for operating Behavior it had
Peak Junction temperature of just 63°
with a peak hot spot of
75° so 6° cooler than the aventus with a
comparable 1500 RPM fan speed and 32 DB
of noise the memory also peaked at just
76° so again 6° cooler than the MSI
model then lastly we have the gigabyte
gaming OC and currently the 4070 TI
version is priced $20 over the MSRP so I
expect this super variant to cost at
least $820 us as for how it handled we
saw a peak Junction temperature of 63°
and a peak hot spot of 75° so the same
results recorded by the tough gaming the
memory though ran at just 68° so 8°
cooler than the Asus model and 14 Dees
cooler than MSI aventus
3x now the fan speed did reach 1600 RPM
for an operating volume of 34 DB but the
call is also clocked at 2,800 MHz and
that's a 4% boost over stock so pretty
good result here from gigabyte so there
you have it the GeForce RTX 470 TI super
seems is about as unnecessary as the
name and by that I mean well we got the
47 ETI a year ago now so it's been out
in the wild for 12 months if you wanted
to buy one you could have bought one at
any point in the last 12 months for $800
us and it was how do I say this one of
my least favorite GeForce 40 series
products 12 GB for $800
us not it it's not not a good buyer not
a good product and so yeah the ref FR
model it is better but it's not that
much better so was it worth waiting 12
months
for of course the biggest issue was the
price or rather what you were getting
for the price $800 for a 12 GB graphics
card was laughably bad when it launched
so I'm glad Nvidia has updated it to 16
GB but it also feels like too little too
late the upgrade just isn't significant
enough to get me excited at the $800
price point
on the other hand the updated 470 super
for $600 that was pretty decent not
exactly an amazing deal but as far as
midcycle Refreshers go it was pretty
good the 4070 TI super though it's a bit
of a wet blanket performance overall is
really much the same we're talking about
a few per uplift so not enough for
anyone to
care it's even worse when you consider
that the RTX 480 will be replaced by the
480 super in a week offering a minor
performance bump with $200 knocked off
the price and if we go off the data we
have here that makes the 407 tii super
just 6% more affordable per frame when
compared to the 4080 but 20% more costly
than the 470 super and really what this
means is that overall a103 products
aren't Great Value but if you're going
to buy the 4070 TI super you might as
well just go the full hog and get the
480 super plus you'll enjoy the added
benefit of not sounding like you're
having a stroke every time someone asks
you What GPU you're running now when
compared to the radon competition the
407 TI super Stacks up rather well if
priced at $750 us the 7900 XT becomes a
bit iffy and I feel paying the extra $50
for the 4072 I super is the way to go
you're getting similar rasterization
performance with generally much stronger
rate racing performance especially in
titles that use rtfs heavily then
there's all the other stuff we often
talk about stuff like the quality of
dlss generally being better than that of
FSR a much better rate tracing
performance better incoder quality and
better power efficiency just to name a
few so for me to take the 1700 XT over
the 407 tii super it has to be no more
than $700 us so a $100 saving or a 133%
discount and again we've said countless
times in the past it's our opinion which
is also backed by viewer data that radi
on gpus need to cost a minimum of 10%
less than the GeForce competition before
they become viable given many of the
things we just mentioned so in a
nutshell for us 10% less is where radon
gpus become viable 15% less is
convincing and 20% less is an automatic
purchase anyway we will continue to
monitor pricing with our monthly GPU
price updates so you can work out what
the best deal is for you for now though
I think we're pretty well done here 4072
super it is a pretty boring product that
at best fixes mistakes of the original
and really this is what inv video should
have delivered to you guys 12 months ago
so that's that makes for a fun uh
product release anyway yeah I really am
done here bit of a boring one this one
um suspect that most of you will agree
but if it you appreciate me spending a
week benchmarking boring gpus then give
the video a like subscribe and if you'd
like to get some more har boox goodness
we have float plane patreon signing up
to either one of those things we'll get
you access to monthly live streams a
Discord server behind thee scenes
content Q&A stuff a lot of cool things
there so check it out if you're
interested but if not perfectly fine and
I would like to thank you for watching
this video I'm your host Steve see you
next time
[Music]